you opened up and you just were able
like you said talking about stuff that
you'd never really talked about before
and you dedicated your dance to other
healthcare workers what's it like to
dedicate that dance to them and sort of
open up in this way
um it honestly it felt like you know I
had an opportunity to really do our
career kind of justice and be able to
talk about it in a way that
um you know that we haven't in a couple
years I feel like there was a lot of
Spotlight and a lot of discussion in the
beginning but for us it's a pretty
grueling profession all of the time and
I think you know we're still feeling the
effects of it as healthcare workers so
just a reminder that you know I'm always
thinking about them and hold them in my
hearts and kind of have this like space
and platform to be able to talk about it
publicly has been a blessing it was a
beautiful performance and obviously
dancing again tomorrow night I mean
multiple dances in one week right out
the gate it feels like I mean how are
you guys feeling and what can you tease
about tomorrow
feeling tired
good on the same page feeling
um excited yeah feeling excited we
worked really hard we are exhausted but
you know now is the fun part we get to
share and show off all the hard work and
I'm excited for prom
um prom was fun the first time it's
going to be even better this time
um and then you know obviously we have
to talk about Selma tonight I mean what
do you think you know the impact she has
left on Dancing With the Stars and sort
of the journey that she's been been on
she's left an incredible impact I mean
she's just so inspiring as a person and
with her story and sharing it with all
of us has also been a blessing and
watching her grow she's an amazing
dancer you know we were all in tears
seeing seeing her leave but she has to
put herself first no it's been a
pleasure to host her in the ballroom
um
yeah I hope I hope we reciprocated
everything that she wanted you know I
hope it was everything that she hoped it
would be and more and that makes me
proud it makes me proud of dance it
makes me par you know be proud to be a
part of the show and uh I hope she comes
back you know I know she doesn't live
far so she's always welcome back to the
ballroom and that is there anything
about doing the show that still
surprised you
surprises you
um
surprises me how
things look like they are never going to
happen on a Friday let alone Tuesday or
Wednesday and every Monday I I watch the
the live show and sometimes even dress
rehearsal is like it is not coming
together I'm not just talking about us
in general I've seen other couples and
then somehow live something just clicks
and something special happens so Dad
continues to surprise me because that is
like a moment of spontaneity that no
matter how much practice how much
production calculation goes into it live
TV live performances just like live
sports there's nothing like it
and then I have to ask lastly
um next week Canadian icon Michael Buble
will be a guest judge yes all right so
how do you think he'll do as a judge and
are you excited
I'm so excited I'm gonna start the
bribing now
um I think we're just all really excited
for another theme night and to be able
to dance to his songs and really
incorporate him and our experience so
just gonna suck up yeah yeah and he's
you know he's not he's not not just on
brand but his music is a really
beautiful soundtrack to This Not Just
genre of Movement Dance ballroom dancing
but also this space I mean this is a
perfect space to host Michael Buble and
his music so I hope he has a good time I
know the dancing that we're getting
ready for not just from us but the group
numbers the opening number I know Derek
is gonna be a part of so uh it's gonna
be a really really great show